So what did you eat for breakfast-
jam sandwich, yeah
You had a sandwich?
Yeah
A jam sandwich?
yeah I always loved mathematics as a kid, so
one of my earliest memories is when I was like
two years old and my grandma was
cleaning the windows in our home,
and I was insisting that she put
numbers on the- she put the detergent on
windows in the form of numbers so I always
liked numbers and patterns and logic
and so forth, things are very
black-and-white where there's one right
answer and everything else is wrong. I didn't
like so subjective shades of grey type
questions, I would work on math workbooks
for fun you know my parents wanted to
shut me up she just give me a workbook
and I'll just go do sums and so forth so I
always liked mathematics, math
competitions- doing that was very
different from doing research
mathematics, the type of problems that
that you've given in a problem book and so forth
these are very canned problems,
things you can do in five minutes or ten minutes
and they don't prepare you completely
for a research problem where, you know,
you have to spend six months, you have to
read the literature, talk to people, try
something, doesn't work, modify, try it
again, and it's a very different
experience doing research but I like it a lot
better actually than– than
all the puzzles I used to do as a kid I
don't do these things very much any more.
My mother was a high school math
teacher when she was younger so she did
help me a little bit you know you know
when I was a kid you know,
just talking numbers with me and then I had a lot of
very good mentors when I was like 10 or
11 there was a retired maths professor
in Adelaide which I'd go visit on the
weekends, we'd have tea and cookies and you know
he would just discuss some some
recreational maths problem, and so forth, which was a
lot of fun. He would tell me stories
about how he'd use maths during World War Two, and so forth, you know,
to do ballistics and so forth. It was kind
of fun to actually see maths actually being used for something
"He had a PhD in maths from Princeton at
20 and was appointed professor of
mathematics at UCLA at 24"
I enjoyed it I mean
when I was a kid I mostly enjoyed
doing math and geeky things and so forth, and
you know, being accelerated and
going to going to uni that early, I was
around people who are older than me
but had similar backgrounds so we were
at sort of the same level mathematically so
you know these people five years older
maybe but we're both stuck on the same homework assignments,
we both like to talk about various math concepts and so
forth so I felt at home you know so I
did miss out on maybe sort of the
regular high school experience you know
sort of– I didn't go to many, you know,
high school social events and so forth I did a
lot of that actually once I was in grad
school in Princeton. So then I
hung around people my own age and you
know, then I partied and so forth,
so I sort of had a slightly reorganized
childhood but it worked out well for me
"And I have to say Terence Tao was
competing there and he only got one out
of seven. Let's actually cut
Terrence Tao some slack, the fields medalist, the guy
who's like coming close to solving the
twin prime conjecture. It's actually
pretty awesome because he was only 13 years old.
He holds the record as the
youngest person to ever have won a gold medal."
- It was this question six.
- Oh yeah yeah yeah
it's a famous question yes.
What's your recollection of it now and why
you didn't get it right?
- No I did not get it right
- How do you feel about that?
- I well you know you win some
you lose some. I -- oh boy -- I have --
it was so long ago now I don't remember much
about it. I do remember once the Olympiad
was over I found out that some
Romanian woman had solved
the question and I remember searching
out for her, because it was really bugging me that
that I did not know how to solve the
question. There's a special trick to
solve it, which at the time was not a
standard trick that was taught to you. You have to use a
method of descent -- you had to... I forget the
exact question. You had to show that
something could not be a perfect square --
was always a perfect square, and show
that if it wasn't you could find a
smaller counter-example and a smaller one
and a smaller one. I think nowadays it's
become part of standard training in
its -- they all know the trick
now, but...
- Were you competitive? Were you the sort of boy
that would get upset about it or was it
just a fascination? "I just want to know
that, I want to know the answer" or
when you like angry you didn't get it?
- I think I was more obsessive than
competitive, yeah, I mean certainly I was
a bit angry at myself for not getting it
but I wanted more to know the answer
than to win, I think.
- There's this
famous image of you with Erdős.
- Yes.
- It was a great photograph. People want
to know what you're discussing in that
picture what's going on there.
- Yes, I
think he was giving me a maths problem
which I did -- I think I even know which -- what it is
because he did send me a postcard
afterwards with what may be the same
problem. I have it somewhere. Yeah I think
it was it was some maths conference in
Adelaide, yeah I was like 10 or something
I don't know why I was there maybe
some math professor at
the University of Adelaide told me to come.
I understand, he was always very good at
at speaking to mathematically gifted kids and I don't remember much
about our conversation except that
I remember I really felt
like I was being treated like an equal
like it wasn't condescending or anything
like you know. It was a very
pleasant conversation you know I mean
now Erdős has passed you know I
mean it does have some sentimental value
for me I mean it's... Yeah, I mean I
certainly wish I'd paid more attention
to him, actually you know I mean like I'd
heard of him you know as a child for
but you know Erdős is someone...
...to me he was just someone who would
like talking math to me, and that was great. He did
write me a letter of recommendation for
Princeton later on so he did help my
career directly.
- Did you ever have people
you looked up to and thought they were...
they were the top guns?
Not really I mean, you
know, I would learn about Euler and
Gauss, and Newton, but these are
largely just names. I think I didn't
really have a sense of... you know so I'd learn
all these theorems and tricks and so forth
but I didn't really ever have a
good sense of what was the most
important, or what was the... yeah I
didn't learn the why of mathematics until
a lot later. I remember when I was
learning calculus, I thought that the
most important mathematician in the world must be
be Taylor, because Taylor's name appears
everywhere in
undergraduate calculus. Taylor
expansion, Taylor's rule and so forth and,
you know he was a good mathematician, but
you know, there were many other
people who did good stuff which is not
taught as much at an undergraduate level.
When you're doing mathematics do you use
any kind of visualization in your head?
What does it look like in your head when
you're doing math?
It's a bit hard to explain. It's always always a combination of
thinking inside your head and speaking
out loud and working on the board. You do
try to isolate sort of the simplest
metaphor or something for for your
problem... How can I explain it... So you know,
for instance, I do a lot of estimates
I always want X less than Y and
sometimes it helps to think of a sort of
an economics problem, like "you have a
budget of Y, and can you afford X?" and
that way you start thinking economically
like so the way you work with
inequalities like X less than Y is that
normally you maybe try to first bound
x by z and z by w and then w by y and
so forth and this is like you know
trading in you know one item for another
item and you get a sense of sort of what
inequalities are sort of good
deals for you that you're getting you're
getting you bang for your buck and which
ones are really wasting your money. Sometimes
utilizing sort of your financial
intuition can be helpful.
Algebra and topology... Those
have always been my my weakest areas.
I've only been able to get a handle
on these areas generally by translating
them into other types of mathematics,
geometry or analysis, I have better
handle on... I certainly don't claim
any mastery of all of mathematics. I think nobody can do that
not since Hilbert. (David Hilbert)
The work I'm proudest of is almost all
joint work and I think
nowadays most of my work is
joint. It is really fun to talk over a
math problem at a really high level with
a co-author who who is really on your
wavelength, understands what you're
thinking. It's actually... saying
things out loud, it almost forces
you to think, like, at a more organized level
than in your head where it can be
a bit jumbled and vague, and it's just
more fun, you know you can go back and
forth and if you're stuck maybe your
co-author has a suggestion if he or she is
stuck you can make suggestions. You at
least guarantee one other person is
interested in what you're doing. You know
when you write something, when you write
a paper by yourself you know there's
always somehow the nagging fear at the
back of your mind that maybe you know no
one will care about this... but you know
you at least have one person to talk about it
with.
What do you think or feel, what's
your impression of those mathematicians
that go the opposite way, Andrew Wiles
is an obvious example, the mathematician who
works in solitude. What do you...
how does that impress you?
What he did
was very impressive... you need both.
You need people who focus very very hard
on one very narrow problem working for
years, become a very deep expert. But then
you need the people who can connect
things in fragmented fields. I make
my living you know by understanding one
field X and taking some ideas from that
and applying it to field Y, but I couldn't
do that if there weren't people who are
very deeply working in in field X, and
so forth, so I think it's great that
there's a huge diversity in
mathematics you know if we all thought
the same way we all had similar
philosophy it would be a much poorer
environment.
You know you can't really call
your shots in mathematics. Some problems,
the tools are not
there. It doesn't matter how
smart or quick you are. The analogy I
have is like climbing, if you
want to climb a cliff that's 10 meters
high you can what we do it with the
right tools and equipment, but you know
if it's a sheer cliff face, you know,
a mile high and there's no handholds
whatsoever, you know just forget it. It
doesn't matter how strong you are or
whatever, you have to wait until there's
some sort of breakthrough, like some
opening occurs like halfway through,
halfway up the cliff and now you have
some easier sub-goal. You know
there's some speculation, there's some
possible ways to attack the conjecture
but nothing is really promising
currently.
You're not climbing that
cliff, but if few foot holes appear you
might run and try and climb it as well?
Yeah, yeah yeah! You know it would... this is
the way it works, whenever there's an
exciting breakthrough like everyone
just sort of nearby in the area just sort of
takes a look at their favorite list of
open problems, "okay maybe this new trick
can give you some advance". It's very hard
to rule out that there's some major
breakthrough in something which seemed
impossible suddenly becomes very very
feasible. This has happened many times.
...that is not the same thing as the full
Kakeya problem because maybe as the
direction varies smoothly, maybe the pole
would have to jump around.